we're told a rollercoaster has C cars
each containing 20 seats and it
completes our rides a day assuming that
no one can ride it more than once a day
the maximum number of people that can
ride the roller coaster in a single day
is P write an equation that relates P C
and our pause this video and see if you
can do that alright before I even look
at the variables I'm just gonna try to
think it out in plain language so what
we want to think about is what is the
max number of people per day people per
day and so that's going to be equal to
the number of cars in our roller coaster
so number of cars times the maximum
number of people per car times the max
number per car so this would just tell
you the maximum number of people per
ride so then we have to multiply it
times the number of rides per day so
times we do this in a new color
times number of rides per day now what
are each of these things they would have
either given us numbers or variables for
each of them the max number of people
per day that's what we're trying to set
on one side of the equation that is this
variable P right over here so we'll say
capital P is equal to what's the number
of cars per coaster I guess you could
say let me write it this way / / coaster
/ a roller coaster so they give us that
right over here roller coaster has C
cars so that's going to be this variable
here in orange or this part of it that's
C now what's the maximum number of
people per car well they say each
containing 20 seats so I'd multiply that
times 20 for this part and then I want
to multiply that times the number of
rides per day for the entire roller
coaster so that's going to be times R
and we're done we could rearrange this a
little bit we could write this as P is
equal to 20
times C R and we're done